>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington D.C.
[ Silence ]
>> Elizabeth Peterson: Hi everyone.
I'm Betsy Peterson, Director
of the American Folklife Center
and on behalf of the staff and
everyone here at the library,
I want to welcome you all today to
the latest Benjamin Botkin lecture.
The Botkin series, lecture series,
allows the American Folk Life Center
to do a couple of things, most
importantly, present the work
of leading scholars and folklore,
ethnomusicology, world history,
and cultural heritage studies.
It also allows us to
enhance our own collections.
All of the lectures here are
videotaped and become a part
of our permanent collections at
the American Folklife Center.
They also eventually make their way
up to our website, and our webcasts,
so that people around the
world and people for future --
and people in future
generations can listen
and hear what you are hearing today.
So with that message, just let me
ask you if you have a cellphone
or any other device turned on,
please turn it off at this point.
And today, I have the great
pleasure of introducing researcher
and scholar Ian Nagoski, who
is the Founder and Director
of Baltimore's Canary Records.
For more than two decades now, Ian
has been involved in collecting
and researching examples of
early 20th Century sound media,
particularly 78s, and in the past
ten years, he's produced dozens
of reissues on the music,
particularly emphasizing the music
of immigrants to the United States.
Last year, as part
of the AFC Symposium,
which is when I first met him,
the symposium was documenting
culture in the 21st Century.
Ian gave a wonderful talk
about his research on late 19th
and early 20th Century Greek
and Turkish performers.
And the biographical
and sociological contexts
of those performances.
Today, drawing on Canary
Record's recent digital release,
and we're sort of moving into
new realms here, called "Ecstatic
and Wingless: Bird Imitation on Four
Continents, Circa 1910 to 1944,"
Ian will explore the
largely forgotten art form
of bird imitator -- of bird
imitators and illuminate the world
of vaudevillians, bird fanciers, and
the performers who studied birds,
poeticize them and try to be them.
Before I turn the mic over, I also
want to say that this research,
this most recent research on
historical brood recordings,
is getting a little bit of
notice, most particularly
and recently it was
highlighted by the New Yorker,
I believe it was last week, because
one of the recordings from "Ecstatic
and Wingless" is a recording of
a nightingale made in Bremen,
Germany in 1913, and
rediscovered by Ian.
And it has been selected
for inclusion in Moon Ark,
the first permanent art installation
on the moon, which is being curated
by Frank-Ratchye Studio
for Creative Inquiry
at Carnegie Mellon University.
And so today, we're delighted to
have Ian join us and talk to us
about Canaries, Nightingales,
Whistlers and Transcribers,
Birdsong, Bird Imitators,
and the Early 20th
Century Recording Industry.
So please join me in
welcoming Ian Nagoski.
Ian.
[ Applause ]
>> Ian Nagoski: Thanks so much.
I'm deeply fortunate,
very grateful, to be here.
What an amazing and strange
turn of events in life.
As Betsy said, I'm
a music researcher
and reissue record producer.
I live in Baltimore,
Maryland, "Bird City."
My name is Ian Nagoski.
I have a little record
label called Canary Records.
My main project over the
past ten years or so has been
on immigrant musics
to the United States
from the collapsing Ottoman Empire.
So primarily, Greek, Turkish,
Armenian, and Arabic speaking people
who arrive in the U.S.,
end of the 19th,
beginning of the 20th Centuries.
Spending a decade swallowing as many
stories as possible of the lives
of people who immigrated from the
Near East to the United States,
I have absorbed enormous amounts
of material related to their exile,
exploitation, murder, ethnic
conflict, genocide, you know?
And I'm tired.
I am. I'm exhausted.
The whole thing has beaten me up.
It's hard.
So, in response to that emotional
problem, five years ago or so,
I started another project
which would try
to keep me sane, was the idea.
All of my work originates in
the process of just digging
through detritus, of leftover
records that nobody wants.
Just junky old, remains that are not
being actively collected or studied
or if they are, it's
only by a handful
of basement dwelling weirdos.
My people.
So among the records that I was
digging through and noticing were --
you know, there's lot of them
around that say on the label,
"Bird Imitation with Piano,"
or with cello or something.
And it was a big, popular genre in
sort of first two or three decades
of the 20th Century, where you
would get some lady doing a little
like twittering, whistle
bird imitation,
over top of some guy playing
"Beautiful Dreamer" on piano
or some other kind of
like sentimental schlock.
They're not good records,
but the fact that there were
human beings imitating animals was
interesting enough that
when I noticed records
of people imitating birds
without "Beautiful Dreamer"
or somebody playing a cello or
whatever, I said, "Well okay,
these I'm going to listen to and
these I'm going to pay attention to
and you know, store those aside."
And then gradually, I began
to notice also recordings
of birds themselves
laying around in piles.
So I said, "Okay, well there's
something going on here.
Why are there records of birds?
What purpose could it serve to
have a record player in your room
and play a record of a bird for
fun in 19 say 15 for instance?"
So, gradually I began to dig into
this and go down this rabbit hole
and I learned the story and that's
the story I'm going to tell you
for the next 52 minutes or so.
I will begin the story with a
quote from a certain Royal Dixon
who wrote a book in 1917 called
"The Human Side of Birds."
He is vastly more enthusiastic
about birds than I am.
I actually don't really
like birds that much.
They freak me out.
They are an alien, reptile,
dinosaur intelligence
that makes me uncomfortable.
However, he does get to the heart of
a certain kind of a personal urgency
in the mission of all of this, which
is why I want to read this to you.
He begins, "It is strange indeed
that so few human beings are
yet aware of the divine songstry
[assumed spelling] of the birds.
We pay large sums of money to hear
concert music and we never stop
to think that the pieces we are --
they're only the musician's ideal
of some aspect of nature.
In his complex civilization,
man has grown away from accord
with the world of the wild things,
that he cannot give its essence
so truly as his feathered
brothers of the air.
Birds render in their music the
glorious spirit of the universe
as it really is and ever will be.
The indifference of a large part of
the human race to the natural beauty
that everywhere, reminds one
of Stevenson's apt words,
'If God would charge so much a
head for sunsets, or send a drum
around at the blossoming
of hawthorns,
perhaps then man would
better appreciate
and adore what has been
his neglected heritage
since first his race began.'"
So music, where does it start?
My contention is that at every
point in the development of music,
every change in its technology,
there has been relationship
and a dialogue with
birdsong, oddly enough.
We will start with the first known
musical instrument discovered
in a cave in Southern
Germany just a few years ago,
apparently made 40,000 BCE.
It's a three-fingered flute.
Plays the pentatonic
scale apparently.
And it is made from
the bone of a bird.
So we start there.
Okay, jump cut 25,000
years, the cave paintings
of Lascaux included depiction of a
bird headed or a bird-masked man.
Jump cut further, 1414 BCE, one of
the first comedies ever written.
Aristophanes, "The Birds,"
includes the earliest known textual
transcription of a birdsong.
In this case, a hoopoe which goes
"Epoy, poy, poy-poy, epoy-poy,
poy-poy, tio, tio, tio, tio, tio,
tio, tio, tio, [inaudible], bricks,
toro, toro, toro, toro, toro,
toro, toro, ticks, kiko-bau, toro,
toro, toro [inaudible] ticks."
Around the same time, Archytas
published a diagram of a dove,
a mechanical dove, which through a
system of cantilevers and pulleys
and pipes, not only flaps its wings,
but also creates birdlike sounds.
It is in fact the first robot
ever created by human beings
and it is the first lifelike moving
mechanical object human beings
ever theorize.
You know, he publishes this diagram.
It's then republished in a book
called "Pneumatica," in Alexandria,
the First Century A.D. And devices
are actually built from this.
And we have the first bird automata.
Through the beginning of the early
modern era, end of the Medieval
or the Renaissance, bird robots like
this become common place in Italy
and are part of the
gardens of nobility.
There is debate among scholars
throughout several hundred years
whether or not birdsong
is actually music.
In 2007, Cornell published
"Song Birds: Music, Nature,
and Poetry in the Latter Middle
Ages," by Elizabeth Eva Leach,
which over several hundred pages
tries to answer the question,
"Was birdsong considered music
or not in the late Medieval
and early Renaissance Europe?"
The short answer is no.
It was not seen as rational.
Well, times have changed and
rationality seems not to be
as important as it once was.
From there, we'll jump cut to 1650.
The first staff notation
transcriptions made in Europe,
of birdsong, occur in 1650
by Athanasius Kircher.
I've given this talk
about a half dozen times.
People often approach me
afterward and say, "Oh,
you know about Olivier Messiaen,
this composer of the
mid-20th Century
who cataloged birdsong
starting in the late 1940s,
and then used the material
of his cataloging of birdsong
to build from, to compose.
Messiaen was the dying gasp of
a 400-year tradition of trying
to notate, trying to take
birdsong, control it, manipulate it,
and communicate it through
the media of staff notation.
Okay, 1717, we get to
the publication of the
"Bird Fanciers Delight,"
or "Choice Observations
and Directions Concerning
the Teaching of All Sorts
of Singing Birds with Lessons
Properly Composed with the Compass
and Faculty of Each Bird."
It is a compilation of
tunes for the block flute,
for an instrument we
call the recorder.
Did you have to play the
recorder when you were a kid?
I did too.
Do you know why it's
called a recorder?
Because it's the instrument
that was used
to record songs in
the minds of birds.
The word record, is in fact --
it's the core, is the heart.
It is repeating over and
over so that it is remembered
by heart is what the word means.
Anyway, so the recorder was this
popular flagellate instrument used
to play to birds, and you would try
to train them to sing
these melodies.
Now you can do it really
well with like bullfinches.
It was a big thing.
You could train a bullfinch
maybe four or five little songs
and like the Queen of England would
pay you know, the equivalent of tens
of thousands of dollars
for one of these birds
that could sing four melodies.
So it is a time consuming process.
You have to -- 20 times a day,
you have to whistle to the bird.
You have to fall in love with it.
It has to fall in love with you.
And then you sell it to some woman
and it won't sing for the woman,
and then the man comes
home with a beard
and the bird starts singing
like, "Oh, I like you."
Anyway, so they sold this book
to people to try to get people,
like "Okay, you play these on
your recorder over and over again,
to your bird -- there's a half
a dozen different birds, linnets
and all these things, and your
bird will learn these songs."
And it was totally just malarkey.
It was like a Popeil, late night TV
you know, jive infomercial thing.
It was a scam, is what
I'm trying to say.
It was a scam.
However, a bunch of the
melodies in that book from 1717,
wind up going into English folklore.
One just a few years later, winds
up in Gay's "The Beggar's Opera."
Eighteen-ten, Johann Bechstein
publishes several textual
transcriptions of nightingales that
he knows personally in his book,
"The Natural History of Cage Birds:
Their Management, Habits, Food,
Diseases, Treatment, Breeding,
and the Methods of Catching Them."
For instance, he introduces one
by saying, "This is the song
of a fine nightingale
without including its delicate
little variations, for among these
as other musicians, there
are some great performers
and many middling ones.
This song is so articulate,
so speaking,
that it may be very well written.
The following is a trial which
I've made on that of a nightingale
in my neighborhood, which passes
for a very capital singer."
[ Bird imitation ]
And then it gets hard and I
can't do the last ten lines.
I keep trying and I keep failing.
Under Bechstein's influence in
1871, in the "Descent of Man,
and Selection in Relation to Sex,"
Darwin describes attending
a canary singing competition
in London in a tavern.
Like record collectors,
canary breeders
and fanciers would gather together
and show off what they had,
get drunk, avoid their
wives and children,
and would have their birds
singing against each other.
Now, the singing -- in modern
times is for quality of tone,
and we'll be talking about
that with canaries momentarily.
At the time, it was mainly for one
of the few things we know for sure,
that female canaries or any bird,
female any birds, like is stamina.
So, Darwin says that, "A first
rate bird will sometimes sing
until he drops down almost
dead," or according to Bechstein,
"quite dead," "from rupturing
a vessel in the lungs."
I don't know if you've known
any musicians in your life.
I've known a few who match
that description quite well.
Eighteen-ninety-six, Charles A.
Witchell publishes, "The Evolution
of Birdsong, With Observations
on the Influence of Heredity
and Annotation," and includes
graphical representation
of birdsongs.
Grids of various sized
black dots as well
as 37 automata poetical
words for bird sounds.
You can find those on my website,
www.Canaryrecords.tumblr.com.
Most of them are not safe
for work, it just so happens.
Okay, 1896, finally,
we get to records--
1896, the first bird
imitation records are made here
in Washington D.C. for
Berliner's Gramophone Company.
February 15th, 1896, one N.R.
Wood cuts a recording called
"Morning on the Farm."
He had to rerecord it five
more times to keep it in print
over the next five years.
In the early days of recordings, the
masters would wear out real quick,
so in order to keep a record in
print, the performer had to go
in and rerecord the piece.
The record company's catalog
described the recording this way.
"A realistic farmyard scene
illustrating the different sounds
attending the early
morning rising on the farm.
This reproduction clearly and
accurately brings out the bleating
of sheep, the lowing the
cattle, crowing of the cock,
the cackle of hens,
squeal of the guinea hen,
and gobble of the turkey, all
being answered by the cries
of the neighboring hawk,
crow, and other birds.
So real is the arrangement
and so exact the imitation,
that it requires but the slightest
stretch of the imagination
to place oneself in that
delightful position.
The result of which is the drinking
in of copious drafts of fresh air,
and numerous other pleasures
attainable only on the farm."
So, 1896, you have a record player
the last decade in the 19th Century.
One of the first disc players made.
And you have available to you a
human being imitating the sounds
of farm animals, because it gives
you an emotional association
with the pleasures of the farm.
Two years later, 1898, one Milton
M. Clark recorded only one side
in his whole career for the
Gramophone Company, that March,
called "Imitation of Birds."
I have so far not been
able to find a copy,
but I know that such
a record did get made.
So those two are the
first recordings
that we know of on disc recordings.
One Joe Belmont may have released
cylinders earlier, but not by much.
Belmont's career lasted
another 20 years actually,
doing bird imitation.
The first recording of actual
birds occurs 1899, made by a --
one Ludwig Koch in Berlin.
Ludwig Koch was the son of wealthy
financiers and they were so wealthy
that they were able to buy sound
recording equipment in 1899
for their eight-year-old
son who then proceeded
to record his own pet Indian shama.
Now, that in and of itself
probably wouldn't be notable except
for the fact that Koch fled
Germany during the 30s,
and landed in London.
Became a prominent fixture
as a newspaper writer
and a radio broadcaster.
The London Times, May 13th,
1940, he wrote, "War or no war,
birdlife is going on,
and even the armed powers
of the three dictators
cannot prevent it.
I would like to advise
anybody in a position to do so,
to relax his nerves in
listening to the songs,
now so beautiful, of the birds.
If one watches carefully, one
can be sure of surprises."
Nineteen-ten, another German
begins recording birds.
His name was Karl Reich.
And Karl Reich had
already gotten very famous
for having taught a
canary a nightingale song.
It was a big deal in the
bird fancier community.
He wrote a bunch of
articles about it, you know,
lectured about it widely, and then
he did something else which was
that he taught a nightingale
to perch inside the horn
of a gramophone recorder,
so that he was able
to get the first really
good, clear recordings
of nightingales in particular.
He recorded a number of birds.
There in Bremen, in 1913,
this recording that he made
of a nightingale had become
something of a thing for me.
I'm going to play it for you now.
How are we doing -- oh good.
Yes, okay, good.
Alright, so this is a particular
nightingale, recorded acoustically
in Bremen, Germany
by Karl Reich, 1913.
[ Bird singing ]
Typically, over the years and years
of lecturing, I've always tried
to not speak over recordings.
I've always tried to let them
play on their own in respect
to the performers, out of you know,
a sense of dignity to the lives
of those who sang, played.
I don't have that luxury today.
I've got to blast through
this stuff really quick.
I'm sorry.
So, this record is --
was an insanely hot
seller, all over the world.
You go on EBay and get yourself one
in like perfect day it was
made condition, right now,
for like a dollar, maybe five if you
really wanted to shell out for it.
It's all over the place.
There are tons and tons
of copies of this record.
It is junk.
It's really good.
So, why was it such a big seller?
Well, there's a lot of reasons.
One of them is because
nightingales are found from England,
all the way through Europe,
through parts of Northern Africa,
all the way through the
Balkans, Turkey, Persia,
down through Central Asia, down
into India, and into Indonesia.
They occur in poetry from Sapho,
Milton, Shakespeare, Homer, Byron,
Keats, Shelley, of course who knows
how many hundreds of thousands
of Turkish and Persian poems
are about nightingales,
particularly the nightingale's
relationship with the rose.
The nightingale you see cannot help
but pour forth the most varied,
the most elaborate, the
most beautiful song,
of any creature on earth probably.
And it when it gets going,
during that period in the spring,
it will sing all night long.
It will go without repeating
itself for like 12 hours.
It is so much better than Mozart,
Ornette Coleman or Charlie Parker.
It's like the best
outpouring of endless melody.
It is the impassioned lover.
It is the poet himself.
So it's like this perfect metaphor
and it occurs over and over
and over again through western
literature of you know, all kinds.
There are no nightingales in
the Americas or in Australia
or New Zealand or you know,
anything for that matter.
So, all of those continents
in 1913, 1915, 1920, had --
most of those people had
never heard nightingales.
They'd read about nightingales
all their lives.
Here, a nightingale in Bremen,
Germany escapes through records
and is sold all over the
world to people who now get
to hear what a nightingale
actually sounds like.
Now, part of this was also
delightful and intriguing
because in 1924, a
composer in Italy, Respighi,
composed this piece,
"The Pines of Rome."
Very famous kind of orchestral
suite thing, tone poem.
And he notates the end of the
third movement, the last few bars,
he writes by catalog
number that this record
of this nightingale should be
played during the last few bars
and into the silence, which
proceeds the fourth movement,
which is the very first time
in the history of recorded --
of music, that a prerecorded
sound gets played during a concert
performance as part of the piece.
I have looked at recent performances
and listened to recent performances
and they do not use this
recording, and I object.
Oddly enough, so yes, there
was a reference earlier
to this Moon Ark project.
I was asked to contribute a birdsong
and there's a ring that's being
inscribed in a titanium object,
that is 16 microns thick and is the
waveform of that particular birdsong
as a contribution to that project,
the Conceptual Art Project.
Part of the reason for that is
because of Karl Reich's other claim
to fame, which is that he and
another guy, Duncker, Hans Duncker,
created the first red canary.
Canaries are what color?
>> Audience
[ In unison ]
: Yellow.
>> Ian Nagoski: Canaries are green.
They are. They're green.
They're all green in
the wild, all of them.
We made them yellow, and
then we made them white,
and then in about 1920, Karl Reich
and Hans Duncker created
the first red canary
which people had been trying
to make for hundreds of years,
and they did it because it was
the first genetic modified animal,
decades before Dolly the sheep,
by splicing in genetic material
from a South American siskin.
Anyway, that's the other reason
that that particular
song is going into space.
Okay. So, oy, vey, vey, vey.
So canaries, canaries --
oh, nightingales where the
preeminent songbird all over Europe
and parts of the Near
East for centuries.
They're great to have
around the house.
You catch them at the
right time, you know,
you really just got a few week
window where the males sing,
particularly preceding the
arrival of the females.
If you -- after they've
paired, after they've mated,
if you take the males --
they're still singing.
If you take them away, they
will go mute and they will die,
apparently of heartbreak.
But if you get them just
in a couple of week window
when they arrive before the
females do in migration,
you can get them to
sing for you at home.
You have to get a -- you get a
wineglass, and you turn it upside
down and you put mealworms
inside and then you surround
that with meat, ground meat, and
gradually, because they're going
for the mealworms and pecking
at the upside down wineglass,
they will get some meat in their
mouth and they will realize
that they can live on
that and they like it.
So you can keep them
around the house.
Otherwise, they have
to have live food.
Also, they defecate wet.
So, there are pros and cons
to having nightingales.
This other bird was found on the
islands off the coast of Africa,
the Canary Islands
they're called which is --
their islands are named
for a dog -- right.
The bird is named for the
island named for the dog.
Keep that straight.
Canaries, it turns out, sing kind
of just as good as nightingales,
and they're shit is dry,
and they eat dry food.
So there are like lots
of benefits immediately.
Also, they're kind of exclusive.
So it was like the Spanish
territory, the birds first go
to Spain and they get, you know, to
France, and then they get from there
to other parts of Northern Europe.
I began looking at canaries
and nightingales in particular
because I was interested
in Greece, Turkey, Armenia,
and the Levant as I mentioned.
Part of the impetus
was because Greeks have
like millions of songs
about canaries.
Turks had like millions of
songs about nightingales.
There are like almost no
Greek songs about nightingales
and almost no Turkish
songs about canaries.
So there's like an
ornithological, ethnological divide.
You know, they're just
split up where they fall
on that ethnic bird line.
But this is the beginning of it.
It's early 16th Century,
canaries are imported into Europe,
and breeding begins immediately.
The royalties start hiring
people specifically to take care
of their nightingales
and begin getting them
to sing the appropriate
kind of song.
Canary song was already
radically different in captivity
by Darwin's time, than
it was in the wild.
We have taken out a lot of
the tropics from their song.
All the squawky, "parroty"
[phonetic] stuff,
like that's all gone.
Over time, we've developed an
ideal canary song by a combination
of breeding and tutelage.
You see, songbirds learn
essentially like human beings
where elders teach younger ones.
And so by exposing younger
birds to elder birds that you
like particularly, you
can over time develop
and build a line, a
tradition of song.
So canary song, as it exists now
in captivity and has done for 3
or 400 years, is a
human composition.
So, I'm going to play you one
of these kind of at its peak.
This is a recording
made in Berlin in 1937,
by the aviary of one F.
Blanc [assumed spelling].
We don't know who he
was unfortunately,
but Germany had been the
hotbed for canary birdsong,
in particular for hundreds of years.
Villages around the Hartz Mountains
in particular, you're maybe familiar
with the Hartz Pet Food Company,
comes from bird supply stuff.
And the canary and coal mine comes
from the silver mines
of the Hartz Mountains.
Canaries were incredibly common
and there were whole villages
where half the population of
the village would be involved
in canary breeding for
export all over the world.
So in Berlin in 1937, this record is
produced as a commercial recording
of a private aviary
for home listening.
This is not an outdoor, field
recording bit of nature.
This is not Royal Dixon's like,
vision of like God in the sunset
and the blooming of a hawthorn.
This is an ideal manmade aviary,
to be listened to by people
who knew what it m[inaudible]
and knew exactly how good it was.
Assuming -- oh.
Human error.
Compounded upon human error.
There we go.
[ Birds singing ]
Now my background is
in electronic music,
and it occurs to me immediately how
similar this particular sound is
to mid-20th Century
German electronic music,
it just so happens.
I have no evidence to see a
one to one correlation, but-- .
Now, in order to create this sound
over these hundreds of years,
beginning in 1630, there
was the invention in France
by one Monsieur Bennard
about whom we know nothing,
except that he invented an
instrument called the serinette,
which is the name for
canary in French.
It was a barrel organ,
specifically tuned and created
to teach a canary an ideal song.
So, human manmade instruments
specifically
for teaching music to birds.
Well, then we have the
invention of the record player,
where we have human beings
listening to birdsongs
at home for various pleasures.
And we also have the use of
records to teach birds now.
We have mechanical recordings
to play for your birds.
This is one of the records that
sent me down this whole rabbit hole,
and I'm going to play
you a brief minute of it.
It was made about 1920 in Richmond,
Indiana at the Gennett
Recording Studios.
I don't know if you're
familiar with Genet Records.
It was an offshoot record label
run by the Starr Furniture Company,
and a lot of -- well, Jelly
Roll Morton recorded there.
A lot kind of foundational
blues and country,
and you know a substantial amount
of popular music was recorded there.
This was a privately made,
privately pressed recording,
made by a Canary Breeders
Association in Louisville, Kentucky.
And what it is, is a human
performance, two people, a duet.
One's playing a flute.
The other one is playing
what is referred
to on the label as a water organ.
I don't really know
what a water organ is.
I've looked at various designs.
I don't see one that
correlates to the sound I hear.
I believe what it is, is
a pump organ of some kind
with little vessels, some kind
of bulb of water at the bottom.
The air blows through over
the surface of the water,
caused a warbling sound,
similar to the sound of a canary.
So this is a recording of these two
human beings, in 1920 in Richmond,
Indiana, to be listened to.
To be played over and over
for aviaries of canaries
to teach them an ideal song.
The record is the same
on both sides.
Both sides were worn to nothing.
So it's a very difficult listen.
I'm sure you can take
it for a minute though.
[ Birdsong ]
So, we have a performance of human
beings imitating animals in order
for the animals to imitate them,
so that the animals will be as good
as we want them to
be, which is like us.
Now, at what point did human
beings begin imitating animals?
I suspect, just a guess, preceding
anything we would call music
or language.
People, whatever people are,
were making sounds
like their environment.
Like animals around them.
I know some people
who can imitate birds.
They're all hunters who were
taught to do so, not from records,
but from like their parents.
Human beings have created
not just the serinette,
but hundreds of different devices
and instruments to imitate birds
for various reasons, many of
which have to do with dinner.
But then there's also the business
of entertaining people
by sounding like a bird.
This is something that
of course you know,
we talked about the
Berliner recordings made here
in D.C., end of the 19th Century.
It became a thing in -- on records.
On early records.
Such that recording in
India began in 1906.
In 1908, there were
already recordings made
in India by bird imitators.
The first one was one
Venugopal Chari.
This one is recording from about
1920, just to give you an idea.
[ Foreign language
spoken and birdsongs ]
When you tell your friends what
you did with your hour at lunchtime
on Tuesday, will they believe it?
Alright, so here's another bird
imitator from about 1910, 1909,
something like that, from
the Alhambra Music Hall
in Paris, France.
[ Birdsongs ]
This is a trained professional.
Self-trained.
[ Birdsongs ]
Through the teens and 20s, there
were dozens if not hundreds
of people who made their
living partially at least,
from imitating birds on stage.
I'm going to play for you two,
in particular from America
that I am especially fond of.
The first one is significant
because it represents a new moment
in the history of women in America.
Parallel with the suffragette
movement, through the end
of the 19th and beginning of the
20th Century, it became possible
for a woman to stand in public,
pucker her lips, make weird faces,
and whistle in front
of other human beings
for the first time
in American history.
There are literally
hundreds of articles,
published between the last
decade of 19th Century,
and the first two decades
of the 20th Century,
that begin with the old saw,
which I'd never heard before,
"A whistling woman
and a crowing hen,
never will come to any good end."
And then the article goes on the
say, "Well, can you believe it?
Not anymore.
Now women can whistle too
and it's perfectly okay
and here's a lady who's coming to
our town and she's going to whistle
for us, and it's going to be great.
And you're going to like it."
For instance, there's a San
Francisco Chronicle article
from June 26th, 1904,
called "Whistling is an Art
and Drawing Pretty
Lips to a Pucker."
And begins with this quatrain, "Boys
may whistle, but girls must sing.
Now I call that a curious thing.
If boys can whistle,
why can't girls too?
It's the easiest thing
in the world to do."
The Pittsburgh Post-Gazette,
April 15th, 1915,
one Dr. L.K. Herschberg [phonetic],
A.B., M.A., M.D., of Johns Hopkins,
"Wishes to reassure you that
your daughters and wives will
in no way be harmed by whistling."
He says thus, "The
hygienic advantage
of whistling is only beginning
to be recognized by psychologists
and public health officials.
Most medical men, however,
especially in the strict laboratory
kind, scoff at the very idea.
Yet, as an aid to health,
whistling is the equal
of most muscular exercises, and far
superior to medicines, mud baths,
and morbid medica-mentations."
It's science folks.
It's perfectly okay.
Now, so women began
publicly whistling
and doing bird imitation
in particular.
One woman named Agnes Woodward,
opened the California School
for Artistic Whistling.
It was one of only -- it
was one of several schools
of artistic whistling opened
around the country about the time,
and it graduated the two most
famous whistlers, female whistlers,
of the early 20th Century.
One of them, who's name I've
forgotten, but you know her.
You've heard her, because she sings
in the first five Disney
feature films.
Snow White, "At the Wishing
Well, I'm wishing," and the bird
in the tree whistles
the melody back.
That's that lady.
And she's not credited in any
of the films because it's Disney
and that was what he did, but
anyway, she was a graduate
of Agnes Woodward's California
School for Artistic Whistling.
The other most famous female
whistler of the early 20th Century,
was this woman, Margaret
McKee, who was born 1898.
Started performing as a
whistler at the age of 9,
before studying with Agnes Woodward.
Performed at churches, ladies'
functions, private homes,
1915 to 1918, including Chautauqua.
Are you familiar with Chautauqua?
It's a similar situation
as this, right?
Yes, yes, yes, so it's infotainment.
Somebody gets up and does
something entertaining and you know,
gives you a talk about how you
should live a tempered life
or ladies get dressed up like and
do you know, tableaus and togas
of Greek sculpture and stuff.
Yes, it's similar to you
know, this kind of nonsense
that I'm doing right now.
So she does that.
By 1921, she performed at the
hippodrome in San Bernardino,
California, where she was lowered
from the rafters in a giant cage,
dressed in yellow feathers.
She toured Europe from 1922 to
'26, and the returned home first
to California and made radio
broadcasts, and then toured
around like, opening for like our
gang movies in Reading, Pennsylvania
and stuff, until 1929
when she struck
up with a Brooklyn Baptist
evangelist named Russell Brower
[phonetic], with whom she
performed twice a week, every week,
until 1935, for six years,
opening for lectures titled,
"The Virtuous Life," and
"Suicide: Is it Ever Justifiable?"
She returned to California
after those six years,
still with her maiden name and
went back to live with her parents.
Recorded into the 30s and 40s at
ladies' teas and women's functions.
She was a great virtuoso
of whistling and made many,
many records, accompanied
and unaccompanied.
This is a little sample
of one from the late 20s.
One of my favorites.
I really like Margaret McKee.
How are we doing on time?
[ Birdsongs ]
So, for what it's worth,
Agnes Woodward, her teacher,
published in 1937 a book
on artistic whistling,
half of which is dedicated to
bird imitation specifically.
So that book is probably here
in the library somewhere.
It's available online for free.
I do recommend it if you're
interested in pursuing the subject
as very few people
seem to do anymore.
Why do people not imitate
birds so much anymore,
and why are there these old
records of them, the question is?
Okay, so old records, the deal was
when there first was a record
business, you would put on a record
and if your ears were to be
believed, there was like the sound
of a human voice or someone
playing an instrument or something.
And yet, you could not see them.
And so for people who for millennia
had been trained from infancy
to expect a sound to be accompanied
by something that you can see,
you know, a source making that
sound, it was a dissociative feeling
and a source of wonder and
joy for a great many people.
Similarly, if a person
is standing on stage,
and the sound of a bird
is coming out of person,
it is a similar dissociative
experience, and kind of amazing.
Kind of -- "Wow, you sound just
like a-- " whatever animal it is.
So the two kind of
cancel each other out.
You put on a record, you can't see
the person causing you the wonder
because the wonder is the record,
and then people became
desensitized to that wonder.
Well, it still goes on
privately in various places.
There are still bird imitation
competitions in various places.
There have been a couple
of TV stars.
There was a guy about 20 years ago
in Italy who made a name for himself
on like Star Search type shows
doing great bird imitations.
But, he was not as good
as Charles Kellogg.
Charles Kellogg was the best there
ever was, and he got very rich
and very famous imitating
birds, among other things.
So I'm going to try and
tell you real quick,
the story of Charles Kellogg,
who I could have spent
this entire hour on.
I love Charles Kellogg.
Charles Kellogg was born
October 2nd, 1868 in a small town
in the Sierra Nevada
mountains in California.
His father ran a provision
store for goldminers.
His mother is out of the picture
by the time he's two
or three years old.
We don't know where she went.
We don't know if she died or
abandoned the family or what.
But anyway, she's gone.
And Charles and his
brother are mainly raised
by Native American
women and a Chinese guy.
So, he grows up actually around
very little English language
for a lot of the time.
And furthermore, he spends pretty
much all the time of his childhood,
up until he's nine years old,
out in the woods, by himself.
And he teaches himself during
that period, to do this thing
with his throat where he would make
the sounds back to various animals.
Snakes, and bears, and birds,
and all kinds of stuff.
He developed a way of
singing with his mouth closed
and imitating animals back.
Now, his father grew alarmed when
he got to be about nine years old
that he was kind of growing up
this wild boy, and he sent him
out to upstate New York to
live with rich relatives.
They taught him woodworking.
They you know, taught him how to
you know, sit at the dinner table.
They sent him to Syracuse.
He graduated during which
time he started a men's choir.
Liked singing.
Just after graduating from Syracuse,
he performed at Chautauqua.
And he was a hit.
What he did is he got up on stage
and he did this thing he'd
learned how to do as a kid
where he would sing like a
bird with his mouth closed.
And people went like,
"That's great."
And he went, "I've got a career."
And he went on tour.
And he toured relentlessly
for the next 50 years.
Where to begin.
Okay, so we've got to plow
through Charles Kellogg.
So Charles Kellogg, what he would
do, he would come out on stage.
The backdrop is painted
to look like the woods.
He comes out dressed
like a woodsman.
He's got this mustache.
He's really good looking.
He looks like a Brooklyn hipster.
He's like super cute, and he
comes out and this bird sound is
like coming out of his throat
as he comes out on stage
with the woods behind him.
And people are going like,
"Wow, that's amazing."
And then, he stops and he
begins to address the audience
and he tells them all about
nature and how wonderful it is.
And if only you just go into the
woods and approach the animals
without fear, and with
love in your heart,
everything will always be fine.
Now, I told this to my daughter
at one point, who's ten years old
at the time, and she said,
"Is that how he died?"
His big break came in a
San Francisco Call article,
December 4th, 1910 after
he'd already been touring
for about a decade.
In that, the writer writes,
"He has the utmost faith
in the power of love and kindness.
'It is all love,' he says.
'Anybody who goes into the woods
with a spirit of love in his heart,
without the faintest desire
for destruction or possession,
can make friends with the birds if
he is merely tactful and patient.
Birds can read the hearts
of men better than men can.
They know their friends and
they're ready to love them.'
In Kellogg's mind, there is
no place for fear or hatred.
Fear creates fear.
Hatred brings hatred.
Love engenders love.
These are the cardinal
tenets of Kellogg's creed."
So that's what he does onstage.
He lectures you.
Sometimes for like
two hours about love,
while he's like intermittently
doing demonstrations of bird sounds
or you know, taking out snakes and
having children come up on stage
and play with the "grass
dollies," he calls them.
And the topper -- okay, so
apparently he'd gotten his hands
on the early edition in
English of Hermann Helmholtz's
"On the Sensations of Tone," a book
on acoustics, foundational work.
So, apparently he'd read this
and it sort of blew his mind
and he got this idea
of an experiment that's
in Helmholtz's book.
So he gets a gas flame Bunsen
burner, and a glass tube,
and he demonstrates that by just
using his throat and the vibrations
of the air, he can
make the flame dance.
And then, he can blast a
note so high and so loud,
that you can't hear it, but
it extinguishes the flame
and "That's the end
of the show folks.
Ladies and gentlemen, Charles
Kellogg," and the house goes crazy.
Nobody'd ever heard of it, so he's
fascinated with vibration and love
and fire and animals and it's
all this one, big package.
And he just tours it relentlessly
and he knows how to keep the press
and the media interested.
By 1915, 1920, when he's playing
in Chicago at the big theaters,
he's making the equivalent
of $100,000 a week.
Like Oprah money.
But then one of the heiresses
of the Kodak fortune seems
to fall in love with him.
She piles a bunch of
money on top of him.
He builds this house out in the
mountains called The Mushroom,
which is a single room with an open
roof, and a fireplace on a track
on wheels that can go around.
He's a vegetarian his whole life.
He never takes a gun into
the woods with him ever.
Takes lots of photographs.
When the interest in his work
starts to fade in the 20s,
he goes to the Redwoods, he
cuts a giant section of a tree
and carves it out with
a couple of axmen.
Builds a room inside the
tree, mounts it on the chassis
of a tank, and then drives it.
It will only go seven miles an hour.
Drives it down the west coast, up
and down making whistle stop tours,
no pun intended, telling people
about the woods and birds
and how great he is, and
he calls the vehicle --
there's been no such thing as
an RV before, remember, in 1925.
He calls it the "Travel
Log," har, har, har, har.
Anyway, okay so I'll play
you some of Charles Kellogg.
Among Kellogg's various claims
that he would make was that he --
well, at first he said he had a
nine and a half octave vocal range.
And then he changed that.
He said, no, he had a ten and
a half octave vocal range.
In any case, it was
enormous, whatever it was.
He also claimed, as you will hear,
to have the actual physical larynx,
the syrinx, of a bird in his throat,
which was such total bologna.
However, he did also claim, and
this is true, he spent a full day
with Auguste Rodin, who fell in --
you know, who was crazy
about Kellogg.
And even though they didn't
speak the same language,
they hung out all day and you
know, looked at art and had dinner
and smiled at each other apparently.
[ Charles Kellogg Show ]
The whole record is four
minutes on the side,
so I'm going to skip ahead.
I just want to play you
a little bit of the end.
[ Charles Kellogg Show ]
My sentiments exactly.
So, just to finish up real quick, I
just want to say that May of 1929,
the first recordings of
birds are made in the wild.
The first non-captive, non-caged
bird recordings by Arthur Allen
from Cornell's Ornithology
Lab made on film.
Nineteen thirty-two, Albert A. Brand
issues a two 12-inch 78 rpm disk set
called "Bird Songs Recorded
from Nature," recorded outdoors
with a parabolic microphone.
And this folks, is about where
captive bird recording ends.
From that point on, we
have various recordings
of folkloric examples
of bird imitation.
So for instance, oh Friday May
6th, 1938, here in Washington D.C.
at the National Folk Festival,
Fred Colby's group from Nashville,
Tennessee includes a
recording of a bird imitation.
It's not very good.
William Lipconde [phonetic]
records bird imitation
in Mato Grosso, Brazil in 1938.
Those recordings are housed at
the Indiana University Archive
of Traditional Music,
etcetera, etcetera.
The last one I'll play for
you today though was recorded
at Arvin California's -- California
Farm Security Administration Camp
by one Charles L. Todd
for the Library
of Congress's Robert Sonkin Migrant
Workers Collection under the WPA.
This is Donald Leach,
recorded August 24th, 1941.
He imitates a variety of things.
Birds are just part
of it, but he's one
of the better performers, I think.
And he was six years
old at the time.
Oh, beg your pardon.
[ Animal imitations ]
All of which is to say that there
is such a thing as joy and wonder
in the stuff that gets behind
in the junk that nobody wants,
the stories that are not so
important to the central narratives
that we continue to tell
ourselves about who we are.
We're actually much better,
weirder, more interesting,
and more fun than what
we claim to be.
You've all been very
kind and patient.
Thank you very, very much.
[ Applause ]
Thanks. Nancy has asked if -- first
of all, if anybody's got to go,
like you're not going
to hurt my feelings.
Perfectly fine.
I know there's -- you
know, life goes on.
Nancy's asked if anybody
wants to ask a few questions?
I'll try. Yes?
>> Stephen Winick: You
know, I've been listening
to our recording series
at the American Folklife
Center for a long time.
One of the best known French
traditional folksongs,
and it's sung everywhere
where French is spoken,
is called "Nuit Sauvage," which
means, "Wild Nightingale."
And the trope of the song is
the lover asking the nightingale
to teach him its language so that
he can woo his girlfriend, right?
Because--
>> Ian Nagoski: Yes.
>> Audience member: -the
nightingale is so good at that.
>> Ian Nagoski: Right.
>> Stephen Winick: And so, I
mean it gets into this question
of bird imitation and why people
would do it, and that's one sort
of traditional answer
to the question.
And I wonder in others -- you know,
you mentioned that for example
in Turkish songs, there are many,
many songs about the nightingale.
What it is about the nightingale
that's being discussed?
>> Ian Nagoski: Oh, there's a
million things about nightingales.
Okay, so in the Turkish-Persian
tradition,
the nightingale sings to the rose.
Male sings to female.
It's a metaphor of you know,
masculine desire and ability
to speak to -- now it also,
nightingales nest low to the ground,
sort of briars and bushes and stuff.
And so there's this long
tradition of the idea
of them intentionally piercing
their own breasts with thorns
out of like the agony of love.
So there's that.
There's another whole tradition
having to do with the fact
that they do sing all night
long, so they are worried,
they are unrestful, they're
looking out for something,
something's bothering
them, they're --
there's one story that nightingales
originally only had one eye,
and worms had one eye, and the
nightingale borrows the eye
from the worm, and then
doesn't give it back.
And then has to stay up all
night watching out for the worm,
because the worm's going to try and
come back and get his other eye.
Yes, so you know, what is
it about ache and yearning?
I mean, the song is thought of as
sad, and you know, I can hear why.
But it's a -- you know, there
are all these projections.
Nightingales are also remarkably one
of the least interesting
looking birds.
I mean they are as boring
and drab as you can get.
They're brown and middle sized
and just nothing looking.
And they sing the best.
So there's all this other
stuff about you know,
God sort of gave colors and all
these great things to all the birds,
and the nightingale
was last in line.
And he said, "Well, I'm all out.
You get song instead."
You know, so all that kind of stuff.
Like there's so many stories.
There's a Bulgarian story
that came up earlier
about a woman her makes
a bet with a nightingale
about who can sing better.
[ Inaudible audience response ]
Oh, I beg your pardon, thank you.
What is her name again, Mag-- ?
[ Inaudible audience response ]
Dragona [phonetic].
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yes, I can't remember the story.
>> Thea Austen: He challenges
her and he says, "If you lose,
you have to cut off your hair.
And if I lose, I'll
cut off my wings."
>> Ian Nagoski: Right.
>> Thea Austen: And she wins.
>> Ian Nagoski: Right, but
she doesn't cut off his wings.
[ Inaudible audience response ]
>> Ian Nagoski: Because she's nice.
>> Ian Nagoski: Yes.
>> Thea Austen: So are they known
for being competitive in vain?
I mean is it-- ?
>> Ian Nagoski: Nightingales?
>> Thea Austen: Yes,
are they thought
to be competitive [inaudible]?
>> Ian Nagoski: No, they appear -- I
can't think of an instance of that.
They appear in Aristophanes',
"The Birds,"
and in "The Conference of Birds."
In both cases, they're lovers who
want nothing to do with conflict.
They're like checked out
and only want to love.
And that, you know.
So. Yes?
>> Audience member: So
nightingales are connected
with romance and passion.
What are canaries known for
within Greek song [inaudible]?
>> Ian Nagoski: Oh,
yes, yes, yes, right.
Well, they're [inaudible]--
[ Silence.
Technical problem. ]
-that nightingale, or
also what ends the idea
of recording a companion
[inaudible] nightingale, you know?
Does that answer your question?
Yes?
>> Audience member: How
does the lark sound?
You know, there's a poem, "And
the lark will fly up and sing,"
and I'm always curious
how it sounds.
>> Ian Nagoski: The Cornell
Ornithology Lab contains a massive
archive of recordings of
lots and lots of birds.
And it's all available,
hundreds of thousands of them,
are available for free online.
I cannot recommend highly enough.
It's such a great resource for
listening to any kind of birdsong.
I can't imitate any birds.
So, I can't really --
I can't do it for you.
I wish I could.
>> Audience member: And
this is only in England.
>> Ian Nagoski: Yes, the lark.
>> Audience member: Yes.
>> Ian Nagoski: Yes.
I'd never heard a nightingale
before myself until I was in Germany
in April, several years ago,
and it was remarkable walking
down the street and immediately
going like, "I know what that is.
Oh man, this is really happening.
I'm really inside of this life."
>> Audience member:
[Inaudible] it flew
up in its early dawn,
right [inaudible].
>> Ian Nagoski: Lark of the Morning.
>> Audience member: He always--
>> Ian Nagoski: Oh, yes.
Von Williams.
Yes, yes.
>> Audience member: He always hears
it when he comes back from courting.
>> Ian Nagoski: Oh yes, yes.
Those associations are important.
There's a line in Dante in the
Purgatory which is, "Lord I,"
I can't remember what
the line is but in Latin,
it's actually onomatopoeia for
a blackbird singing in February,
too early to hasten
along the spring.
So it's layered with not
only the literal meaning
of the words themselves, but
also with the association
of the onomatopoeia of the bird.
There are these things that kind of
occur in poetry in the onomatopoeia
of all the birdsongs
that are kind of fun.
So.
>> Nancy Groce: I'm sorry.
We're running out of time but I want
to thank Ian Nagoski
again for a great talk.
And--
>> Ian Nagoski: Thank you very much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at www.Loc.gov.